short-hair don't care and then it throw  in some bangs if you're Bethenny Frankel  don't hit the player at the game the  star has it chopped her locks once again  at showing off the new do on a snapchat  and Instagram it's very little winter  surprises like whimsy Bethany debuted  the look at a Real Housewives of New  York a viewing party Wednesday night  sponsored by what else skinny girl and  if you're wondering if the hair is a wig  and check out this snap  according to be it's all real she proved  that with some of Bed Head at during a  Thursday morning run it to target oh the  gates of heaven are opening I need  nothing in here at all but I'm coming to  buy stuff I don't need a dick